how high in the air are these guys this
looks like great fun and only slightly
terrified
I want to do it how his shark is
slip-and-slide with such amazing results
Charles's slip inside works by taking a
piece of plastic and place it on a hill
and then flowing water over the top of
it the water acts as a lubricating layer
so Charles slides down the thing and set
it sticking to it to get the maximum air
time the riders must leave the take-off
ramp of 45 degrees going as fast as
possible now the natural slope of this
riverbank means that the riders will be
only traveling at 30 miles an hour or 48
kilometers an hour and this wasn't
deemed fast enough for the slipping
slide to be truly epic so what he's done
is added a motorized pull mechanism
which is literally a rope hooked up to
the front of a car tire which spools the
rope up and pulls them down the slope
and then launches them off the ramp now
the trick is that this car is a
differential when you fix one of the
tires the other tire will spin freely
and they've uses to their advantage here
by lifting the pulley wheel off the
ground
but keeping the other three wheels
locked on the ground the pulley wheel is
easier to turn therefore it gets all the
force from the engine with the gas fully
applied the rider a yanked down the ramp
as quickly as possible so one small step
on the accelerator equals one giant leap
for mankind
you